good afternoon everyone
i'm grateful to be here with the
president as we release his budget for
next year
as the director of the office of
management and budget i deal with a lot
of numbers and charts and graphs and
they all matter
but that's not ultimately what budgets
are about
budgets are value statements
they're about the kind of country we
want to be and the type of future we
want to leave our kids
and from day one the president has been
clear that my job as omb director is to
ensure that the government delivers for
all people
and that our budget reflects our
national values and priorities
i'm proud to say that's exactly what
this budget does invest in the american
people in a fiscally responsible way
this budget will help ensure that
prosperity prosperity is broadly shared
that we continue growing the economy
from the bottom up in the middle out
that we make sure it works for working
americans who've been left out and left
behind
who haven't benefit from the economic
progress they help make possible
that we are prepared to meet the full
range of challenges and opportunities
ahead of us
and it's a budget that includes
proposals all americans can come
together around and that speak to our
country's values at its best
and that's why it's my honor to
introduce the president of the united
states joe biden
thank you
well good afternoon
it's folks a busy couple days
for all of you
the um
let me begin by saying that thanking
director young
you know uh you've heard me say this
before
over the years
my dad had an expression he said don't
tell me what you value
show me your budget i'll tell you what
you value
don't tell me what you value show me
your budget and i'll tell you what you
value well the budget i'm releasing
today sends a clear message to the
american people that we've what we value
first
fiscal responsibility
second safety and security and thirdly
the in exchange in investments needed to
build a better america
the first value is fiscal responsibility
a previous administration as you all
know ran up record budget deficits
in fact the deficit went up every year
under my predecessor
my administration is turning that around
last year we cut the deficit by more
than 350 billion dollars
this year on track
cut the deficit by more than 1 trillion
300 billion dollars
1 trillion 300 billion dollars
that would be the largest one-year
reduction in the deficit in u.s history
and here's how we're achieving this
record deficit reduction
first
we're growing the economy we've created
a record 6.7 million jobs since i took
office
and we've generated a gdp growth of 5.7
percent the best economic growth we've
seen in this country in over 40 years
this has led to substantial increase in
government revenues and dramatically
improved our fiscal situation
secondly this record economic and job
growth has made it possible for us to
responsibly and significantly cut back
on emergency spending
early in the pandemic
it was right to give people help to make
ends meet to keep their account this
economy going
because of the progress we've made
dealing with these emergencies the labor
market is strong and unemployment
unemployment claims are at historic lows
we ended the pandemic unemployment
assistance programs because americans
are back to work
i'm calling for a new pandemic subsidies
for large businesses to not continue
those because those businesses are back
and moving again as well
but because we have to put this economy
in a strong foundation
even the delta and omicron variants of
covet 19 and the cost of putin's
aggression in ukraine have not required
additional an additional fiscal package
for state and local governments
but we still spend what we need to spend
to continue to fight covet but those
expenditures will be dramatically less
than last year
compared to 2020 we're reducing the size
of the deficit
relative our economy by almost
two-thirds
reduced inflationary pressures and
making real headway cleaning up the
fiscal mess i inherited
after my president's my my assuming my
predecessor's fiscal mismanagement
we were reducing the trump deficit and
returning our fiscal house to order
now the budget i'm releasing today
will continue this approach it makes
prudent investments in economic growth a
more equitable economy while making sure
corporations and the very wealthy pay
their fair share and i would add nobody
making less than four hundred thousand
dollars a year will pay a penny more in
federal taxes
we can do this by one passing
legislation that lowers costs for
families on things like child care
health care and energy costs
while lowering our deficit at the same
time we can give hard-working parents
raising children tax relief that gives
them just a little bit of breathing room
and lowers child poverty
we can give medicare the power to
negotiate lower prescription drug prices
this will bring down the cost for
seniors and reduce the deficit by
hundreds of billions of dollars
congress can do this this all right now
they're debating it now
we can also restore fiscal
responsibility
the trump tax cuts added two trillion
dollars in deficit spending and largely
helped the rich and the largest
corporations
under my plan as i said no one making
less than four hundred thousand dollars
a year
will pay
additional single penny in taxes no one
if you don't make 400 grand you're not
going to pay a single penny in
additional federal taxes
and the wealthy incorporation will
finally begin to pay their fair share
for most americans the last few years
were very hard
stretching them to the breaking point
but billionaires and large corporations
got richer than ever
right now billionaires pay an average
rate of eight percent on their total
income eight percent that's the average
they pay
now i'm a capitalist but uh just i want
i if you make a billion bucks great
just pay your fair share pay a little
bit
a firefighter and a teacher
pay more than double
double the tax rate that a billionaire
pays
that's not right
that's not fair
and my budget contains a billionaire
minimum tax because of that with 20
minimum tax it applies only to the top
100 of one percent 100th of one percent
of the americans will pay this tax
the billionaire minimum tax is fair and
it raises 360 billion dollars that can
be used to lower costs for families and
cut the deficit
as i said my budget also ensures the
corporations pay their fair share
in 2020 for 50 fortune 500 companies
that made 40 billion in profit combined
but didn't pay a single solitary cent in
federal taxes
my budget raises the corporate tax rate
to 28
far lower than the rate it was between
world war ii and 2017 when it was
lowered
as of today
last year
i rallied more than a hundred some of
you were overseas with me 130 countries
to agree to a global minimum tax for
corporations doing the business in the
in their countries to put an end to a
tax system that rewards multinational
corporations for shipping the jobs and
profits overseas and avoiding taxes at
home
it's my hope the congress and access law
this year so i can sign it and we can
get to work
the second value my budget reflects is
security
security at home and security abroad
my budget my budget tackles security in
two key ways first
it secures our communities at home
this is an issue families in every part
of the country face
i've said it before
the answer is not to defund our police
departments it's to fund our police and
give them all the tools they need
training
and foundation
and partners and protectors in our that
our communities need
the budget puts more police on the
street for community policing so they
get to know the community they're
policing
allows the bureau of alcohol to back on
firearms and the fbi to hire the agents
they need to help fight gun crime and
other violent crimes in our communities
and funds body cameras and make sure
police work with our local communities
and are accountable to these communities
it funds crime prevention and community
violence intervention
drug treatment mental health criminal
justice reform and re-entry for people
coming home after incarceration
all demonstrable ways to reduce crime in
proven ways
security also means national and
international security
this budget provides the resources we
need to keep americans safe
ensuring that our military remains the
best prepared
best trained
best-equipped military in the world
this budget also provides additional
funding
to forcefully respond to putin's
aggression against ukraine and its
economic humanitarian and security
consequences
the world has changed in addition to
dealing with terrorist organizations for
the second quarter of the 21st century
once again facing increased competition
from other nation states
china and russia which are going to
require investments to make things like
space and cyber and other advanced
capabilities including including
hypersonics
and this will be among the largest
investments in our national security in
history some people don't like the
increase but we're in a different world
today
america is more prosperous more
successful and more just when it is more
secure
we can restore fiscal responsibility and
safeguard our security at home and
abroad while meeting the third value
what i call building a better america
let's provide universal preschool
cap the cost of child care at seven
percent
of a family's income
like many families that would cut the
cost of child care in half
let's make it'll make college more
affordable my budget doubles the maximum
pell grant
the people families making under fifty
thousand dollars a year to nearly
thirteen thousand dollars
and helps more than eight million
students who rely on pell grants pay for
college
my budget invests in building more home
to keep us up to deal with the
skyrocketing cost of housing for the
middle class and the poor
my budget lowers family energy costs
with tax credits help people make their
homes more efficient
research and development to broaden the
versus the reach of solar and build a
clean energy future
my budget also invests in other areas of
bipartisan common good i call them unity
agendas i spoke to them in the state of
the union
beating the opioid the opioid epidemic
taking on challenges of mental health
supporting our veterans
and ending cancer as we know it this
budget includes investments to get
americans the mental health services
they need and we need them
and when it comes to fighting cancer and
other diseases
my budget funds a new organization
called rph that's health and human serve
at the department of health
and it stands for advanced research
projects for health
it's based on darpa the defense
department program that led to
breakthroughs and technologies like the
internet gps and so much more rph will
drive breakthroughs to prevent
detect and treat diseases
including alzheimer's diabetes cancers
and more
here's what this all adds up to
historic deficit reduction
historic investment in our security at
home and abroad by modernizing our
capabilities in both areas
an unprecedented commitment to building
an economy where everyone has a chance
to
succeed a plan to pay for those
investments that we need as a nation
that's what we do
so i look forward to working with the
members of congress democrats
republicans independents to deliver this
budget and keep the living for the
american people i want to thank you all
and god bless you all may god protect
our troops
let me uh
kelly o'donnell nbc
thank you mr president do you believe
what she said
thank you sir do you believe what you
said that putin can't remain in power or
do you now regret saying that because
your government has been trying to walk
that back did your words complicate
matters
well you asked three different questions
i'll answer them all number one i'm not
walking anything back
the fact of the matter is i was
expressing the more outrage i felt
toward the way putin is
dealing and the actions of this man
just just
brutality
half the children in ukraine i just come
from being with those families
and uh and so but i want to make it
clear i wasn't then nor am i now
articulating the policy change i was
expressing the moral outrage that i feel
and i make no apologies for you personal
feelings sir
your personal feelings my personal
feelings
secondly you asked me about uh
well what was the second does it
complicate the diplomacy of this moment
no i don't think it does you know the uh
the fact is that we're in a situation
where uh
um
what complicates the situation at the
moment is the
the escalatory
efforts of putin
to uh continue to engage in carnage the
kind of behavior that
that makes the whole world say my god
what is this man doing
that's what complicates things a great
deal and uh
but i don't think it complicates at all
let me go to steve hall reuters
mr president thank you when you say that
you're not walking anything back you do
feel that vladimir putin should be
remained from removed from power is that
what you're saying no what i was i was
expressing just what i said i was
expressing the moral outrage i felt
towards this man i wasn't articulating
the policy change
and uh i think that
you know he continues on this course
that he's on he is going to become a
pariah worldwide and who knows what he'd
come becomes at home in terms of support
are you concerned this remark might
escalate the conflict no i'm not
i'm not at all
lord thank you
and you know look the other thing is
that uh
a couple people have asked me as well
might well speak to unless you want to
ask the question but uh
you know that other governments have
suggested that this is a problem i'm
escalating things
uh no
and as a week in nato
no it hadn't
nato has never ever ever ever ever ever
been as strong as it is today
never
expressing my outrage he shouldn't
remain in power just like you know bad
people shouldn't continue to do bad
things but it doesn't mean we have a
fundamental policy to do anything to
take putin down in any way what made you
add that because that wasn't in your
prepared remarks we were told so what
made you add that at the end mr
president because i was talking about i
was talking to them to the russian
people the last part of the speech was
talking to the russian people telling
what we thought
i was communicating this to not only the
russian people but the whole world
this is this is just stating a simple
fact
that
this kind of behavior
is totally unacceptable
totally unacceptable the way to deal
with it is to strengthen and
put
keep nato
completely
united and help ukraine where we can um
uh cleve you had a question
where is he
uh thanks mr president
i'm on your on your budget uh
you've said repeatedly at the state of
the union that you're not for defunding
the police i i do wonder how much
emphasis you think should be put on
alternative forms of crime prevention
not just defending the police but uh you
know crime reduction in communities oh a
significant amount i've laid that out in
detail in the budget for example we do
know that intervention programs work we
do know that what police need they
they need psychologists in the
department as much as they need extra
rifles they need people who are in the
department who can deal with the crisis
that the police are going through as
well
dealing with their crises did they deal
with their mental state and how they're
handling things they need out they need
social workers engaged with them i lay
it all out there's a
and it all works if you see these
community intervention programs they
work they actually reduce crime they
significantly reduce crime so that's a
big piece of it it's a follow-up is any
is any of it related to political
pressure from republicans saying that
democrats are soft on crime that you
know that you guys are creating to the
left and that kind of fascinating when i
first got elected i was being beat up
because i supported the police too much
from the previous 30 years
no
that's what i think
um
and uh
um
osmo
surprisingly thank you mr president
um
are you
are you willing to try to meet with
vladimir putin and i have a quick
follow-up to that when you last met with
him face-to-face in geneva you would
describe that as a productive
conversation you said that he did not
want a cold war
and
do you feel
given the actions though that have
happened over the last few months i
guess i'm asking what has changed
in his mind
i don't know it's changed his mind his
behavior has changed
when we met remember what we were
talking about we're talking about
setting up a strategic dialogue
and talking about the relationship of
nato and russia and facing off in the
regions and how we could have more
transparency and all the rest it was a
normal discussion i had going all the
way back to casigan and others back in
100 years ago when i was a young senator
and so what changed was
nothing nothing remotely approaching
that remember when he first met with he
said i have two objectives
this is the second or third time i met
with him
he said i have two objectives one
is to make sure that that they never
become part of nato and two to make sure
there are no
long-range missiles in there in ukraine
i said we could deal with the second one
easily but we can't close the door on
the on the first
because when we talk about missiles we
want to talk about what's also on the
russian border heading toward europe do
both
and uh and then if you notice that
demand list of his not with me with
others have escalated significantly in
terms of what he thinks is is necessary
thank you
thank you thank you very much i know
you're going to ask a really nice
question well it's it's an important
question i think are you worried that
other leaders in the world are going to
start to doubt that america is back if
some of these big things that you
say on the world stage keep getting
walked back
what can he walk back it made it sound
like just in the last couple days uh it
sounded like you told us troops they
were going to ukraine
it sounded like you said it was possible
the us would use a chemical weapon and
it sounded like you were calling for
regime change in russia and we know
none of the three occurred
none of the three none of the three mr
president you you interpret the language
that way i was talking to the troops
we're talking about helping train the
troops in that are the the ukrainian
troops that are in poland that's with
the context i sat there with those guys
for a couple hours that's what we talked
about
so when you said you're going to see
when you're there you were not attending
i was referring to with speaking with
and talking with the
ukrainian troops are in poland and when
you said a chemical weapon used by
russia would trigger a response in kind
it will trigger a significant response
i'm not going to tell you
why would i tell you you got to be silly
the world wants to know the world wants
to know a lot of things i'm not telling
them what the response would be then
then russia knows the response
all right i'm gonna take two more
questions one two
mr president thank you um i still want
to get back to your original words that
he cannot remain in power
can you help us understand you have more
foreign policy experience than any
president who has ever held this office
whether those are your personal feelings
or your feelings as president you
understand why people would believe you
as someone commanding one of the largest
nuclear arsenals in the world saying
someone cannot remain in power is a
statement of u.s policy and also are you
concerned about propaganda use of those
remarks by the russians
no no
tell me why you have so much experience
you are the leader of this country
because it's ridiculous
nobody believes we're going to take down
i was going to i was talking about
taking down putin
nobody believes that
number one number two what have i been
talking about
off since this all began
the only war that's worse than one
intended is one that's unintended the
last thing i want to do is engage in a
land war or a nuclear war with russia
that's not part of it i was expressing
my outrage as the behavior of this man
it's outrageous it's outrageous
and
it's more an aspiration anything he
shouldn't be in power there's no i mean
people like this shouldn't be ruling
countries but they do
the fact they do but doesn't mean i
can't express my outrage about it last
question thank you you've said that
you're confident that your comment won't
undermine diplomatic efforts but just to
be clear are you confident that vladimir
putin sees it that way that he will not
use this as an escalatory uh i don't
care what he thinks look here's the he's
going to do what he's going to do
put look but you're not concerned that
he may see your language and view that
as a sign of a reason for escalation use
that as an excuse to escalate given his
recent behavior
given his recent behavior you should
excuse me i shouldn't say that to you
given his recent behavior people should
understand that he is going to do what
he thinks he should do period
he's not affected by anybody else
including unfortunately apparently his
own advisors
this is the guy who goes to the beat of
his own drummer and the idea that he is
going to do something outrageous because
i called him for what he was and what
he's doing i think is is just not
rational
it depends no it's not a question the
question is is there something to meet
on that would justify
him being able to end this war and be
able to rebuild ukraine that's the issue
sorry can you say yes or no mr president
whether or not you would be willing to
meet with president it depends on what
he wants to talk about
thank you okay last question um
what if he wanted to talk about
negotiations now what if he wanted you
said supreme court
well you can't leave that hanging
just real quick um
two matters on the supreme court there
while you were away um
there were reports about the wife of
justice thomas
uh and texts that she had with former
white house chief of staff mark meadows
should justice thomas recuse himself
from any cases involving the january six
insurrection or former president trump
at this point i'd leave that to two
entities
okay go ahead i'll go ahead and ask the
second question no two entities go ahead
sorry
one
the january 6th committee and to the
justice department that's their judgment
not mine so on justice thomas recusing
you don't think he should or i'm not i
said that i told you those things get
into legal issues that in fact i told
you i would not tell the justice
department what position to take or not
and i'm not going to instruct the
congress either and did you get any
chance to watch much of the judiciary
committee here
the fact that republicans were
questioning
judge jackson on matters like former
sentences related to child pornography
cases or the definition of a woman
does that is the former chairman of the
judiciary committee make sense to you
look this is one of the most qualified
nominees ever
nominated for the supreme court
in every respect
in terms of her disposition
her intellectual capacity
her experience and background and
serving on two three
additional courts
a woman who is totally thoroughly
qualified
totally thoroughly qualified it'll be a
great addition to the court of my view
thank you
thank you mr president
thank you sir